[inaudible]
what I will say about Madonna,
the gays are going to kill me.
I saw her one time and it
wasn't great. New York, uh,
confessions, confessions on the dance
floor. It wasn't, it was in DNA. Oh,
that's the one. Yeah. That was
the whole dance album. Right.
We know confessions was the dance.
Okay. So that day was like in 2012,
I think I was on Mtma when I went to
the, you went, that's where it was. Okay.
I paid a lot of money for those tickets.
We were at Madison Square
Garden somewhere out in Jersey.
I was way up there in the rafters
and I was just like, yeah, yeah,
I'll wait until I'll wait until they're
at the Farewell Vegas tour where she
finally does all the things
that people want to hear.
Right, right. Well, age wise,
she's, she's getting there. Yeah.
But you know, she keeps it together.
She keeps it together. She does.
She does. All right. Let's, uh,
let's talk a little bit about,
I've heard Candace talk about how most
black people actually are conservatives,
but they sort of don't know it or they
can't accept it because of the way the
media has treated black people.
That the default position is you must be
a democrat. Yeah. Do you sense that? Um,
I sense that and to get into that,
you really have to understand how
deeply entrenched this idea, um,
that black people have to be Democrats
is, and, and I said this a little bit, uh,
on the vice thing that I did,
we have black celebrities,
entertainers,
ball players,
athletes from the top of
the charts to the ants.
The thought with 10,000 followers.
These are all people that are
pushing leftists. You know,
they're pushing leftist
tactics and black people.
We more so than I think other races,
we look for representation and media
and we look for representation and pop
culture. And these are our heroes. These
are the people that we want to be like.
And that's one of the reasons why this
idea that we have to be on the left is so
firmly entrenched. So why do you think
that is? Looking for it sort of elsewhere,
do you think that has something to do
with the black family and some of the
stuff that Larry elder would talk about?
It has everything to do with,
with Larry elders talking
about Larry Odor will tell you,
and I'm pretty sure he did that,
the number one to kick the shit out of me.
That's what woke me up.
But Larry elder will tell you that the
number one problem in the black community
is, is black popping it.
Listen to this, right? That we
don't have men in the homes.
And so when there's not a man in the home,
when there's not a man to,
to raise that young man in the home,
they look to athletes, ballplayers,
the Colin Kaepernick's, whoever.
And so when Colin Kaepernick,
just to give an example,
if some kid's hero, right?
And he sees Colin Kaepernick taking
a knee for black lives matter,
and that's where he's
getting his politics from,
because that kid doesn't know who I am.
They could certainly doesn't
know who Larry elder is.
And the fact that that kid is not gonna
know who Larry Elder is. It's a shame.
You know what I mean?
And so that's the message that we get.
Even though black people do tend to
be a little bit more conservative,
just in terms of if you,
for example,
said that black people need fathers in
the home and we need to stop having kids
out of wedlock and we need to start doing
all of these things that will elevate
ourselves. You're a racist
white supremacist, I would say.
I would say everyone regardless of race,
should have those things to
the best of your ability.
Not to say it can't happen otherwise.
You just said you were
raised by your mother.
I want to do turned out
pretty good course. There are
those outlier cases. Yeah.
But at the same time I was,
I went to the military for five
years and so the military taught me,
the military gave me a male influence.
Um, multiple male influences.
The military taught me how to be a man.
The military taught me discipline.
The military taught me courage in
the military taught me self control.
The military taught me reliance,
all of the things that a father
is supposed to teach you.
And so now me as a,
as a gay black man saying these things,
you know, if you're a white
person, you know, you're
white supremacist or whatever,
but I'm sorry about that, you know? Yeah.
I'm, I'm the COO and I'm the uncle Tom,
I'm whatever.
And there is this very huge movement of
like very far left gay black men who it
seems like they have these large online
platforms and it seems like their entire
goal in life is to just tear down straight
black men or tear down the idea of
masculinity or tear down the idea that
our boys need men in the homes to teach
them how to be men.
So they want to tear that down.
And when I look at their platforms and
I look at the things that they say,
and sometimes they get,
they come after me and I ignore it
because none of those people are my enemy.
There is nobody that is out there that's
a public figure that looks like me.
That is not my enemy. That is my,
these people are not my enemy.
But when I look at the
platform that they have, I say,
you have so many people listening to you.
Why are you always preaching
divisiveness and hatred?
Why did you trying to tear down black men?
We should be lifting each other up.
We should be empowering each other because
you know our community meets. Yeah,
well it seems to me that mostly, and
it's not just with say those black men,
but anyone that buys in
to the far left ideology,
they want conformity and they, there
is some sort of, as I say all the time,
Peter Boghossian,
he's been on the show many times,
calls this postmodern ideology a secular
religion and they don't want a PA state
and they especially don't want to pass
states that look like you. That's crazy.
I've never,
I've never really heard that.
I mean I've talked about that
idea and some of my lectures,
but I've never heard it say quite
like that because this is my thing.
And one of the best things that happened
for me over the past year is that if
I'm a religion and I found God,
because I will tell you,
and you probably know there and I don't
know, I don't know what your religion is,
but for me there's a lot of people
that are running after Twitter,
followers and fans and Instagram followers
and fame and money and all this other
stuff and not,
there's not an amount of Twitter followers
or fame or any of that stuff that is
going to fill that hole
that you're looking to fill.
And your Twitter followers don't fill.
The existential void lays out
what you're telling me do not.
The black hole of existence is not
filled by Instagram. Line is nodding.
You've got like 10 times my following.
And when,
when things started taking
off a little bit last year,
like when when my life started getting
bigger and in some other ways I had to
make things smaller. Um, and so
I made my circle smaller and,
and I tried to get close with
my husband and my best friends,
but I also found God. And it is you not
religious before, were you not, were you,
were you specifically not a believer
before? No, not at, not at all.
I was raised in the church
African Methodist Episcopal.
Um, so the AME church,
like I was there and when you're young
and black in the church churches a full,
like an all day event,
I'm there at 10:00 AM per Sunday school
and then you do the service and then
it's two 30 dinner. You're like, again,
not out of there until after dark.
But I think that in my first 11 years in
the city when I was kind of doing some
of the don't ask, don't tell
activism and trying to find my path,
I was looking for fulfillment in all
of those things that I told you before.
And when I started getting those things,
I realized that not that it wasn't enough,
but there needs to be
something else to ground me.
And one of the biggest things that the,
the Super Far left tells young gay
people is that God is your enemy and
Christians are your enemy.
And Evangelical Christians want to
put you in conversion campaigns.
Just all of this crazy stuff to separate
them from relation so that this far
left ideology becomes their religion.
And I,
I say that, you know, God is
a gift in my life right now.
And I say that and I'm not embarrassed
by that anymore and I don't feel like
that's something that I should be ashamed
to talk about even as a, as a gay man.
Somebody described me on Twitter when I,
and I think it's funny, and they said,
I'm former military leftist
turn right wing Bible thumping,
Trump tarred. And I thought
that that lot words, I,
it was hysterical.
I showed that to my husband.
We both cackled I don't hear
you Bible thumping. No, I mean,
I'm not a Trump tart and I,
you know, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Right wing Trump tart.
I don't Bible thump.
I just, I talked that,
I talk about religion in my life and
how it's grounded me and how it's become
just a really powerful guiding fours and
it is fulfilling and it is grounding in
a way that, let me tell you something. As
a young gay man, like, like all the sex,
all the partying, all that stuff.
Like I did it all and there's,
there's nothing in that in for me.
It is becoming grounded
in religion and God. Yeah.
Do you think a lot of gay people have
like an extra struggle when it comes to
sort of be existential questions?
Cause I know I definitely did like that.
You are something that society tells
you at least, you know. How old are you?
Huh? How old are you? Am I allowed
to ask how old you, I'll be back.
I just get to the one question that I can,
I'm in my thirties
during your thirties wow. Wow. Yeah.
Yeah. All right. So that's how it is.
Well I as an elder, I am 42
years. Okay. So you know,
when I was in say high school and college,
you know,
this is way before gay marriage, you
know, during don't ask, don't tell. And I,
I never really saw sort
of a functional future. I,
it's not that I saw dysfunction future,
I just saw no future. I was just like,
I'm now and I'm just going to keep
living now. Something like that. Um,
but I do think for a lot of gay people
that causes like this weird, uh,
belief schism or something like that.
So it's interesting to hear
that just in the last year,
you've come back to some of this stuff.
And I think a lot of people have,
by the way,
I think they are in, in, in, I want them
to, and it's like, so we, we told the,
I guess I don't,
I don't want to say right wingers anymore
because I guess I'm a right winger now,
but they always say that,
you know,
you can't call gay lifestyle
because it's my sexual orientation.
It's a lifestyle. But there are elements
of it that are very lifestyle oriented.
The, the party lifestyle, the circuit
party culture, the gay culture,
like all of that other stuff.
Um,
I don't like any of that stuff.
Yeah.
I like the golden girls who
doesn't like the golden girls,
like gay enough for me.
You know what I mean?
I watched three hours of the golden girls
on a Sunday morning. I'm very happy.
The cool thing right now is that people
like you and people like me can reach
these young people and they can see
something that is outside of all of that
messiness. And I come to it is
not somebody that judges it.
But if somebody that did it all now,
I never did drugs. That was never,
I was never a druggie.
I don't even like smoking weed.
They say that people that are um,
better,
a little neurotic and I'm a
little neurotic. They say we,
it doesn't go well with us and
it doesn't go well with me.
So I never did the drugs.
Yeah,
you haven't found the right end that good,
but I get it.
You're a conservative now.
Yeah. No, it's not even that because
some of them, and it's really funny,
I'm like to the right of some
people on marijuana legalization,
but that's a whole nother issue.
We can go there, but yeah, good.
But I did all the partying.
I did all of the circuit parties and I
traveled and kissing boys and having lots
of sex.
It's like I did all that.
And I fundamentally know
that there's nothing there.
And I think that the problem with
reaching these kids right now is that I am
like,
it feels lonely because it really does
feel like I'm one of maybe three or four
people that like have these large
platforms and obviously you as well,
but they see people that are like,
you know,
they see the drag queens and the Hollywood
celebrities and all that other stuff.
I just really want these kids to see
that they can have a more grounded life.
And not that I'm trying to be anybody's
role model in a way because I'm like,
my thing is I did all the mess.
So you don't have,
yeah, I, I feel there even
though I didn't do the math.
I mean I did do my own mess in
a way. Yeah. Like, and I did,
I did do the drugs and I didn't do all
that, but I wasn't really into the scene,
let's say. But I do feel that too. I'm
not trying to be anyone's role model.
All a hundred. You are setting up for
failure. Yeah. And I, I lived through,
if anything, I would say I lived
through shit to get to where I am.
So that hopefully the next,
that that gay kid that's 18 doesn't have
to do it. You know what I mean? Yeah.
We're living right.
Cause everyone's got shit right.
And the people that came before me live
through far more than that. So yeah.
But there's an interesting parallel here
with the way Hollywood treats all of
this. Because you mentioned something
about, or just a moment ago,
you mentioned how,
uh,
the black culture puts more emphasis
on Hollywood and these figures and
everything. And I was thinking like,
even just in the Oscars last year,
that Black Panther who was nominated
for an Oscar, now I've seen every,
so I think we're going to have a
little difference here because I,
I've seen every marvel movie I just saw,
I end game a couple of days ago. Uh,
this one's going to make me
go see it at this weekend.
I don't want to say
anything right now, but, um,
but I've seen every one of the movies. I
love superhero movies. I Love Star Wars,
love all that stuff. Black Panther was
a very average movie there. There was,
in my opinion,
there was nothing racist.
Same for same racist what? Guess
what? Mary Oliver, you said it too,
but he's a self hating black guys.
Like you just can't win here button.
But my point is, but it was within
the scheme of superhero movies,
none of them get nominated
for anything and that's fine.
But it was very average in my opinion.
It was just a very average movie and it
got nominated for all these things and I
saw the media was like, ah, see
Black Panther. Got It. Like,
like it was some major wins that would
somehow make people more equal or feel,
or now we can look at the numbers
and go this many black films,
this and this many white friends is,
and I was like,
it just seems to me that the aim is just
so off of where you should go for the
prize. The real prize. And I agree
with you on that. First of all,
I love Black Panther. I really
do. Like I'm a, I'm a huge fan.
I thought it was perfectly fine, but
you got an Oscar Award winning nominated
to make a really good point in minority
communities and specifically the two
groups that I'm a part of,
blacks and, and, and gay people.
We always look for representation in
the media as some sort of barometer of
progress. And that's a trap. It's a huge,
it's a big triangle.
Chinese people do it. Yeah.
Because they're focused on making money.
And when I tell him and I'm all about it,
and when I go give these lectures,
and I told people that the biggest way
for any group of people to achieve any
kind of power is financially.
It is not through the Oscar nominations.
And that stuff is great and
it's amazing, but it's, it's,
it's kind of like these are,
these are false idols because Black
Panther is great for visual representation
and it's great that all
those people on the stage,
and I personally think this amazing movie,
but what that does for the young black
kid that's struggling in the high school
that I went to right now, not
much. Not much. Right. Um,
and we do it as gays and
lesbians as well. If, you know,
if somebody comes out and look
at the, look at the, the, the,
the Buddha judge thing
right now. Um, yeah,
look at how people in this
is somebody that is, I mean,
I'm not a Buddhist rotator at all,
but I, it seems to me, you know, I,
I see the game,
I see what's going on and I see the way
that he picked a fight with pence to,
to ingratiate themselves to the far left
though. He's like, I get it, I see it.
But just the idea that any power
comes from media representation,
it's,
it's false hope.
And it also separates the people
from what should be the end goal.
Because I think that empowerment for any
of our communities only comes through
entrepreneurship. Look at this, look at
that. That is your name. On that sign,
you are an entrepreneur.
And if somebody had given me the message
about entrepreneurship when I was 17,
18, 1920, God knows where I'd be by now.
And one of the biggest things that
I've gotten out of out of become a
conservative and kind of moving
over to the right is the fact that
entrepreneurship and capitalism
is not a bad thing in my,
both of our communities need more of it,
but especially my black community,
we need more entrepreneurship.
We need more job creators.
We need to stop looking for
representation in the media to, to,
to elevate ourselves,
to make us feel good about ourselves.
So when you see then the Democrats, so
just in the last couple of weeks, yeah,
there's now this debate suddenly
about reparations and I,
I saw the video of Senator Elizabeth
Warren talking about reparations and she's
going to commission a panel about
reparations. And my first thought,
the first thing that just popped into
my head as I was watching it was,
holy shit,
Candice did it.
You know what I mean? Like
whatever anyone thinks it, Candice,
she created enough of a crack in that
layer that that caused black people to
either be completely afraid of saying
they're conservatives are just,
just say that they're not Democrats. Yeah,
yeah. That now the Democrats are like,
Oh shit, what do we got left?
Here's money. Could you take,
yeah, I bet some money in the
words of the Great Candice Owens,
fear in handouts is what they have
to offer black people the cycle.
And it is no mistake,
first of all,
that Donald Trump got more
African American votes in
the two previous Republican
nominees combined.
That is just the fat.
And it is no mistake that you know what,
you know,
people say a lot about the Brexit
movement and they say it's not real.
It's not that.
And what I tell people is that you're
going to see Republicans make a bigger
play for the black vote than
you had ever seen before.
I think in the history of this country.
And it's not going to come
through fear and handouts.
It's going to come from talking to the
people that are the real job creators in
the real entrepreneurs and saying that
these policies will help you create.
And the fact that reparations is even
a conversation right now among the
Democrats means that they're scared.
Um, I, I just did a video for,
for turning point about reparations
and not to spoil any of that,
but none other than Bayard Rustin who
is one of the architects of the march on
Washington,
a huge civil rights leader who by
the way was black and gay in the 60s.
They interviewed Bayard Rustin about
reparations in 1969 and he said,
it's, he said, this idea is ridiculous.
And the quote is something like,
if my great, great grandfather, you know,
picked cotton than
reparations are owed to him,
but he's dead and nobody owes me anything,
but this is how they're going
to try to buy the black vote.
It's also just a crazy way of
dividing this. Yes. Each other.
I was at a cousin's wedding on my
husband's side this past weekend and,
uh,
was with a young guy who's 21,
22 and he was telling me about how
woke it is in college. Now this,
this is a kid who grew up, his mother
died when he was very young. He grew up,
he had no money, bunch
of different homes, uh,
all sorts of crazy history.
In the family and it's like the idea
that this kid has privileged because he's
white and we're going to take from him.
I mean that's in essence,
that's what he was saying here, like it
wasn't specifically about reparations,
but just this idea that this kid is
somehow guilty or somehow privilege just
because of the skin color,
having nothing to do with
everything he's lived through.
But that's what they're pushing
on everybody. I mean, you know,
that's what they're pushing
and, and there's not a lot
of pushback to that idea.
And I just feel that there's a correction
going on right now and there was a
correction because you're seeing a lot
more conservatives that are younger and
Brown or in whatever. And there's a really
different movement right now. And the,
the, the leftist it, it's like, I
call it the intersectionality coal.
The intersectionality Colt will eat itself
because there's all these things that
you cannot see on the left right now.
And there's somebody who,
I'm not going to name, but this is this
person. It has a platform as a feminist,
right? And this is a male feminist
and I'm like, great, you know,
do what you gotta do.
But don't call me Trans phobic for
defending women's sports or women's spaces
or,
or lesbians who are now,
who now feel pressured into having
relationships with transgender women. Um,
when, when you call yourself a feminist
and you're not standing up for,
for lesbians, and I standing up for
women in that way, I, I, you know,
you can call me whatever you want to
call me, but I'm, I'm always going to,
to stand up for, for lesbians to stand up
for women in that way. But like I said,
the intersectionality coat, there
are things that they can't say. Um,
there are things that they can't say
about radical Islam. You know, when,
when they run into a gay
bar and kill 49 of us,
and then they can't say that you got
Jonathan Capehart running around talking
about, oh, this guy was a closeted gay in
this guy was this, and this guy was that.
And I'm like, that is completely
ridiculous and not true.
And we know that that's not true now,
but the intersectionality Colt will
eat itself because there it is.
It is becoming to the point where there
are too many things that they can't say.
So people like you and I have
to say the things that they can.
Is that doubly tough then
for you as a gay black man?
Because the culture, if we're talking
about black culture and gay culture,
there's so much humor richness there.
Political, incorrect, yes. Yeah.
All of these things. So for someone
like you to be fed these, these ideas,
you've obviously rejected now.
Yeah.
But to be fed these ideas that would
stop you from joking the way you want a
joke or saying something politically
incorrect. The rest of it, it's like,
like I remember going when I would go to
gay bars and they would be like a drag
queen now I, so I again,
I was never into it.
I thought drag queens were all bad comics.
Like they all struck me as just
hack comics. That being said,
they would say a ton of
politically incorrect shit.
They would mock gay people.
They, I mean they would mock everybody.
That was the point. Yeah. We're now,
it's like, I don't know, I don't
know what's going on in the,
in the drag queen world these days.
But it's like,
I'm guessing it's gotten pretty bad cause
they're probably really afraid to say
anything.
Yeah,
you'd be irreverent. I mean I, I think
that right now, I mean I, I'd love drag.
I ru Paul's drag race. I'm like,
I'm all about it. You know, my,
my husband and I are big fans.
I voted for the, in the last last
night vote voted for Gary Johnson,
but I used to live in West Hollywood so
I had to go over there to, to vote. Yeah.
I was standing behind
Ru Paul at the voters.
Wow. Not In drag. And you
want to talk about like,
and you want to talk about how crazy
the left is. Let's talk about Ru Paul.
Let's talk about the crazy blue chairs.
Crazies on the LGBT left
coming after Paul. Like the,
forgive me for being gay. Mvaa
you come from mother, you,
you say that Ru Paul is transphobic or
she doesn't represent gays. And whatever.
Well, what was it that she said? Was
this about a year and a half ago?
This is about a year and a half ago.
Like ru Paul did an interview where
she says she doesn't, we're Paul. Hey,
because we'll pause. A man,
Rupaul said he doesn't believe,
and in transgender women in drag,
because drag is supposed to be a male's
elevated and comedic idea of what a
woman is. And so they came after Ron Paul
for that. They came after there was a,
I'm a segment on drag race called a
sheet shemale girl. You got shemale.
You know what I mean? And so they kept,
the blue techs came after Rupaul for that.
And so it's really funny when I look at
the Ru Paul situation and we'll look at
somebody who has done more for,
for LGBT culture than maybe anybody
walking on this earth right now.
And the fact that people are attacking
him after everything that he's done tells
me that these people are insane,
tells me that there's not enough.
And if there's one thing that I wouldn't
[inaudible] I don't know if this is a
critique because I,
I love Ru Paul and by all accounts I
hear people say that Rw is amazing.
It's not like real kind of bend the
bending the knee a little bit. Oh,
he apologized. We're bending
the knee a little bit. Um, um,
so people coming for him and I want to
get to a point where we are not bending
the knee to the mob anymore. Yeah.
They came after Ellen degenerate.
What lesbian on this planet has done
more for freaking gay and lesbian
visibility in an Ellen degenerate came
after Ellen just because she sat down
with a Kevin Hart and Hart having the
conversation with Kevin Hart and they came
for Ellen.
And so this is what I say,
if they're coming for ru
Paul and Ellen degenerate,
they'll come for you and me so die.
So I will never been the knee. I was,
um,
we were supposed to have
an LGBT conservative panel
at the LGBT center in New
York City. Um, and when, you
know, people found out about it,
where you've got excommunicated from the
center because we were all racist and
all white and transphobic
and all of that other stuff.
And so I will never apologize
for things that I say.
I don't try to offend people,
but you're certainly not going to control
my tongue and I'm not going to bend
the knee to these people.
And I'm really glad that Ellen didn't and
I hope Rupaul never does again because
these are two people that have done more
for this community that anybody in the
planet, certainly not some blue check
mark that writes for some blog. Right,
right.
But we create this reverse or this
perverse I should say incentive structure
where it's like there's a lot of
value for those blue checkers.
We go after them cause it's like,
oh you can wound one of the heroes,
even if they were the ones that
paved the road for you. Wow.
If you can build your
castle on their blood car,
Cardi B says they do anything for cloud
cloud chasers. That's all they're doing.
And the fundamental
critique that I have with,
with a lot of these people that the
cloud chasers is that the platforms are
always built on destruction.
It's canceled culture.
So everything is always built on.
If I build a platform of of let's say
like a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand and my
platform is completely built on tearing
people down,
like I'm going to go up to Dave Ruben
because he's got 10 times my following and
he said something I don't like,
so maybe I'll get some attention for,
for tearing him down. You
know what I mean? So if your
platform is built on that,
then you always have to look for new
things to be offended by new people to
destroy new cloud to chase.
And I don't think that it goes
anywhere, you know? So it's also sad,
right? It's like it's deeply sad. I mean,
I see this with this crew going after
me all the time and I just ignore it,
but it's like the idea that you're
waking up in the morning and go,
what did Ruben say today so I can
get some clicks? It's like, man,
there's so many things going on in the
world that the Fed and it's like I'm not
perfect and I've made mistakes
in this very room on this show.
But it's like if you're waking up going,
this is the guy we got to go after. I,
I adore value than it says about me. It
does. And I, and I feel sorry, I just,
I feel sorry for their life because I
just, there's nowhere to go from that.
And I would like to use
these opportunities that
I'm getting right now too.
I want to engage people,
but I also want to empower people.
I want to empower my people
is much crap as owns gets.
And Man, she gets the a level
that I couldn't even dream of.
She is a true believer.
She is really out here
trying to empower people.
She is really out here trying
to wake people up. And I um,
I saw Bernay Brown special, I think
our name is Renee brown on Netflix.
So she uses apparently enormously
huge motivational speaker,
but I'd never heard of, um, so she just
got, um, promoted to be on Netflix.
So I decided to watch a little bit of,
of the um, special and she said that,
and I think she, I think this
is a Theodore Roosevelt quote,
she said that don't worry about critiques
that come from people who are not in
the field,
who are not in the battle,
who are not putting themselves out there
in some way and trying to affect change
in some way.
And now that I've saw,
I've seen that that's how
I try to live my life.
And because you can't
take all these critiques,
there's a point where you can get 90%
of love from people and we'll follow
because sometimes in the than a, hey,
you know, I was really doing stand up.
I always remember I could be killing
like 300 people laughing hysterically.
If there's one guy look at his phone, it's
like, that's the guy I'm looking at it.
That's it. There's a guy that was
asleep in my lecture last night.
Did you call it out? I did. I said,
I didn't call him up directly,
but I was like giving my speech
and I was like, you know, and,
and I think that everybody needs to have
conversations. Even that guy is funny.
He wake up. He did. He
did. All right, good. Uh,
I'm sorry we didn't do
more of this earlier,
but tell me a little bit just about
your service having nothing to do with,
with all of this stuff.
Only in that, yeah,
just, you know, my service in general,
I think that when I look
back at the military service,
what I regret is that,
you know,
people come up to you when
you're a veteran and they
thank you for your service.
And like people call me a hero
and all that other stuff in it.
I'm always uneasy by that because I
didn't do anything particularly heroic.
I was a young kid. Um, just,
just trying to make it from
one day to the next. I mean,
I was doing things that I believed in,
but when I look at some of these kids
that are serving right now and they're the
same age, I was, you
know, 1920, 21 years old,
it's so much for a young
person to take on. But for me,
when I look back at it
and it just, it, you know,
I lost weight and it gave me
discipline and it gave me kind of that,
that strong male influence
that was missing in my life.
And when I talk about my service,
it's not so much the day to day of what
I did because it was really, you know,
I did one tour in Kuwait, I did one
tour in Iraq right after the invasion.
Um, you connect those dots, you
can get to that age question. Yeah,
yeah. [inaudible] it, yeah.
Connect the dots. It's okay.
Um, but when I look back
to that, we were just,
I was just trying to do the best that I
could and everybody that I served with,
we were just trying to do our best.
And I,
the people that are serving the military,
they are heroes from like from the guy
who captured a Sama Bin, Ladin indies,
these great men that you see these
books from and all that stuff.
But just the people that
give up three, four, five,
sometimes 20 and 25 years of their
life to be of service in some way.
Like there is a very
heroic element to that.
And I think that with me and my service,
I talk about it a lot and I talk about
loving America because it has given me so
much.
Just that service has just put me onto
a path that just sitting here with you
right now and coming back from being
with Candice and going to events in the
White House, like what were
black kid from Akron, Ohio could,
could see that vision for himself in
the military put me on the path to doing
all of these things.
So I don't look at myself as heroic,
but I look at all the people that are
serving now as as heroic. It's to me it's,
it's very strange. I feel like I'm
not giving you an answer, but no, no.
It's very hard to reconcile who I am now
with who I was then and to see that as
anything other than a scared
kid doing the best he could,
if that makes sense. It does make sense
and that feels like a nice ending. Yeah.
How do you feel about that? I think
that's a great ending. Absolutely.
I don't know what I'm doing later,
but there would be something if we just
showed up at the Abbey in West Holly.
Oh my God. Can we find some other
banded deplorable. Oh my goodness.
We should, we should make it happen.
We should, we should make the,
the conservative gay meet up or something
like that. I should make it happen.
Classical liberal. Oh, that's
right. Classical liberal.
Come on you for more on Rob.
Follow him on Twitter at Rob Smith online.